six one seven eight three zero four
seven five zero is the number we will
see who is next on the phone here what
is your name and where are you calling
from my name is Joe and I'm calling from
Philadelphia Pennsylvania alright great
to have you on what can we do for you
today
so I've been thinking a lot throughout
this Democratic primary we saw such a
large schism between you know the kind
of people who thought that were kind of
behind in implementing like social
programs that the rest of the world used
very successfully yeah to raise standard
of living for people and then those who
believed in more of like an incremental
change and I think it because Donald
Trump is running Hillary Clinton's
managed to get a lot of the people who
were more on the Bernie side but my fear
is that you know maybe in the next four
years if we get a Republican who's a
little less scary that the Democratic
Party won't be able to galvanize that
kind of support so my question to you
was what do you think that the
Democratic Party could do to kind of
reconcile some of this this disconnect
or are we just looking at like a
splintered left in the future I I don't
know that we're looking at a splintered
left necessarily because the left you
know there are some voters on the right
who are pragmatic and they say listen
even if we have Trump who is not like if
you're an evangelical right winger and
you look at Trump even though he did win
with that group it's not a group that is
completely overwhelmingly thrilled with
Trump but they are going to some of them
will vote pragmatically and they'll say
well listen we're not voting for Hillary
Clinton and I think on the left there is
even more pragmatic sentiment where yeah
there are some Jill Stein supporters but
I think on election day when it comes
down to it Jill Stein is not going to do
nearly as well as some Green Party
supporters are hoping she will do the
majority of Democrats and and left-wing
voters are going to say right now given
the choices we have the biggest danger
is Trump being president and I'm going
to vote for Hillary Clinton just to try
to prevent that from happening I think
what you're suggesting a splintered left
it's not impossible but it would really
depend on
so if if Bernie Sanders had won the
Democratic primary there were some
Hillary Clinton supporters who started
going sort of anti Bernie towards the
end of the primary most of them no doubt
would have supported Bernie Sanders but
maybe that moderate more center left
center center right area of the
political spectrum would vote for
Hillary over Trump but maybe they feel
that bernie is too far left for them and
only in a scenario where there is truly
a further left-wing Democratic candidate
do I think there's a risk of the
Democratic Party fracturing in that way
Democrats tend to always be very clear
most of them that you know even if
Hillary is to the right of me I don't
want Donald Trump to be the next
president and I'm going to make the vote
on November 8th that will help prevent
that from happening so I think it's an
interesting question only in very
specific situations do I imagine it
would really become an issue but if one
of those situations comes up it could be
really really important and it could
affect the future election thank you so
much for the call I really do appreciate
it that is going to do it for calls for
us today we will of course take more
calls next week and I really really
appreciate everybody who called in today
david pakman.com slash membership that's
the one place to become a david pakman
show member